welcome to Exit 8 the exit 8 from the
description I read it is a endless loop
where I'm supposed to look at you and
study every detail of your freaking
life I
think I'm not 100%
sure am I supposed to look at everything
it's kind of like a I'm on observation
duty but in a
hallway
something feels slightly disorienting
about
this
uhhuh yeah I don't know if I'm actually
supposed to go
anywhere like I don't know if I'm
supposed to go towards exit number
eight
but here I
am it's dist disturbingly quiet oh hello
if it isn't my good friend I haven't
been looking at the poster so I have no
idea if there's any differences or why I
would need to study any differences well
well well if it isn't Mr
mustache receding hairline phone in left
hand briefcase in right no
socks white shirt black pants
man yeah keep on walking which is what
you're doing
uhhuh uhhuh uhhuh so what happens if I
don't notice
something is is there anything bad going
to happen is there a sign that's going
to be like yes smoking like if I spot a
difference I don't exactly have a report
button so then again I don't really know
if that's what the game is about oh look
who it is strolling down my way like he
owns a place just because I'm shoved
over on the left side which I don't know
if this was this imbalance before but if
it isn't Mr no
socks mustache receding Airline white
shirt black pants briefcase phone man
not even going to give me the time of
day are
you jerk yes smoking no definitely still
not
smoking keep left one of these days I'll
be able to keep right again I don't know
if the floor being the way that it was
was the way that it
was feel like I'm getting shoved over
more look what the Cat Dragged In if it
isn't Mr phone briefcase shoes no socks
white shirt black pants mustache and
receding
hairline you think you're better than me
is that what you think you think you're
better than me you can't even look at me
I'm too lowly for you to look at you
think that just because you you have
just some fancy office job that makes
you better than me it
doesn't you're just as low as me pal I
bet you can't even remember what I'm
wearing I don't even know what I'm
wearing I'm I'm an enigma I'm changing
every day every second shut
up I think I got to him that
time I'm living
rent free in his head is there always
another sign
here oh
wait don't overlook any anomalies if you
find anomalies turn around immediately
if you don't find anomalies do not turn
back to go out from exit
uh
okay what was
that well well well am I not even
allowed to turn around if it
isn't H these same three posters three
doors uh
nope no no not doing that not oh not
today nope not today sorry that smile
not for me not for me oh good hey wow
that's that's
something so the thing is I don't know
what was an anomaly outside of the man I
know the man super good but I don't know
anything else about that
hallway well if it isn't my good friend
my buddy my pal uh my main
ombre okay phone in left hand briefcase
sh mustache dreary
expression
uh-huh seems good all seems good here
now if there's like a
subtle
that
pan I'm I'm going to go with it I'm
going to go with it I'm going with
it I'm good I'm good baby I'm good I'm
good exit number two
huh all right yeah I got this there's a
camera up there I got to remember that
too I
think I'm not sure if there was a camera
on every space no smoking three doors on
the left two vents on the right three
doors on the right two vents on the
left um these posters seem
okay phone no
shocks white shirt black
pants okay posters all seem the same
then again I'm not really paying
attention to them and I'm definitely not
going to remember the writing on
them it could
be
it could be I don't
know okay I made it I think I think I'm
doing good guys I think I think I'm
doing great I think I think I'm really
getting it this
time okay oh nope there's only two doors
on the
right yeah that Ain that ain't it that
that ain't it that that wasn't it
sorry been playing too much observation
duty to be tricked by something like
that so far so
good
mhm three up wait oh two vents okay
there are two vents how about you buddy
you okay buddy dreary D
sour okay everything seems fine the
vents might have been in a different
position but I I don't know it seems
maybe it was
okay oh good wait no wait zero what do
you mean where the vents in a different
spot where the vents in a different spot
zero what do you mean zero what do you
mean zero I thought you were going to
kill me okay so it's not it's not a
death defy oh wait a minute no wait
that's an
anomaly this is this is an
anomaly that's a trick but where does it
go I'm too tempted to see where it
goes I really want to know I don't know
what that's about that's
weird it's just kind of
odd Exit Zero oh good oh oh I made it oh
good for for me oh
oh
what did I did I win I don't think I won
hello I don't think I did that I don't I
think that might have been definitely a
no I can run
yippe all right Exit Zero sure
okay got three doors no smoking two
cameras two patterns a big sign that
says Exit 8 that might have been missing
from the other one what about you
buddy you you you good you are have um
how
hi this
what in the freak are you talking
about what are you talking about oh my
God is that that oh my God oh my
God don't do
anything don't don't do H that was an
anomaly okay that was yeah that was I I
I don't know I didn't
connected I thought it was just
something fun happening I thought I was
just having a good time I thought that
was
thought that was good for me good for
everybody involved I thought we were
having just a jolly old
time
uh-huh
uh-huh seems good okay we got one nice
nice good very good very very good what
what is a there's a clicking that occurs
there's like a click clack that that
occurs am I supposed to even remember
like the details on these posters
because I'm not going to do
that more than that I'm not going to be
able to do that rather than by choice
okay seems
good I'm just waiting to turn around and
like the back half of his clothing's
ripped off and it's just a layer of
lingerie probably it happen all right
two we're good we're good we're so good
camera o
loading did you change something camera
camera camera two doors no
smoking okay
dentist store pet
shop again clickey
clack
uhhuh seems good
nope nope nope nope I mean admittedly
there could just be a power outage but
that yeah that's that's a big no on that
one not trying that not waiting around
for it no smoking dentist store dog
three doors Two
vents one of these days his head's just
going to snap around and look at me and
I'm not I'm not ready for that
I'm not ready for that Concourse I
should remember that that says Concourse
on the back if that is what that's
always going to
say yes yes
yes camera was there always a camera
there
maybe
maybe Holding Out for something a bit
more obvious if this is going to be an
anomaly
just what did I just
see was that an anomaly or was that just
a graphical glitch I don't
know I it might have just been a
glitch concour
I think I think I
think what
happened oh no no
no fine it probably wasn't even that
that might have been a glitch and it
just didn't register don't don't do
don't no no I I oh man oh man man
that's you son of a [__] you think you
think that I can make you anomalous by
throwing you off track huh huh huh yeah
oh yeah oh what's what what's up oh
what's up what's going on huh what
what's with you huh you want you you you
got a problem you got a problem with me
huh you think you think you think that
you think that just you sorry do you
need to do you need to take that
you want to you want
to kiss I'm so sorry I read the read
from all
right what is with the sound like a
door okay seems
good wait
Concourse yeah
definitely what what's wrong what is
wrong what did I do
wrong
I don't
know what am I doing wrong what am I
what am I not seeing what are you guys
seeing that I'm not
seeing how am I not seeing
something again what is that about what
is
that
why this in and of itself is an anomaly
that's anomalous
behavior that by looping it's
anomalous by seeming to be right and
being wrong it's
anomalous that's the only explanation I
can have for that particular
one no nope no I don't I don't I don't
need to hello peekaboo shut up go
away I don't even need to talk to
you seems fine
seems
fine
no
no you bastard you
bastard
oh you
[__] I hate
you I hate you I hate you are you
taller that ain't right okay all right
there must be something that I'm missing
in the
Baseline that I'm not seeing am I
supposed to look at these posters maybe
there's something on the
posters I have no idea that would be
really difficult to
remember
uh-huh seems
fine okay so that was good that's the
Baseline is that light always
on is the light always on I think so
I I think
so I bet these numbers do
change
[__] okay maybe not Maybe not maybe
not whoa Speed Demon okay no thank
you all
right
hi bud how you doing 88 there are
numbers on here that seem big and
emphasized that probably can change 129
it just looks so the
same wait a minute wait the spacing
something's odd about the spacing wasn't
that even between those wait no
no no no ah damn it I'm going to get
this I'm not going to let it beat
me 88 oh God hello no thank you okay so
the posters do change we did get
confirmation about that great good to
know no oh my God what's going on there
bud who who taped up your
face all right
goodbye weirdo I have a feeling that
like me finding those stairs actually
might have been the ending and I just
bugged my way into it which I don't know
but it's
possible seems
fine but I've been wrong about that
before
okay it was
fine good
[Applause]
okay hi how are you
doing
uh you
got hi
you what no
oh man screw
you I mean it's totally understandable
why would I walk towards the creepy
twins that's kind of a horror movie no
no no no no no no no no it's a trick
it's a trick that's not the real exit
that's not the real exit I have to
remember that that's not the real exit
that's not the real exit all good good
good
good what but what was
different what is
it oh God damn it the one time I don't
look at the back of that oh I knew that
[Music]
would whatever no that ain't right I
don't know what wasn't right but
something wasn't right it just
immediately jumped out to
me well I clearly not right and I'm not
screwing around around with these things
anymore I'm not going to wait around to
get got by some horrible demon
monstrosity seems
good okay I I i' I just have a feeling
now that I'm going
to be utterly confident and then
something's going to go horrifically
wrong maybe I should watch him leave cuz
that's kind of important too cuz if he
doesn't go all the way around the corner
it doesn't
really There's an opportunity for
something to go horribly wrong there is
that Waldo oh I hate this cuz it seems
good but I feel like I've had too many
seems good in a
row
SC okay f five five five is
good five is
great five is good five is a new
record I think
anyway there always a ceiling tile there
yeah I still couldn't tell you what the
thing was that jumped out at me last
time that was immediately like oh
something's horribly
wrong something did jump out at me is
that t always there I think it
was there's always a click right as I
pass that
door the posters are
bigger wait yeah wait these posters are
huge that's not
right how did I not notice that
immediately how how did I not notice
that
hi excuse me did you notice the posters
are
huge cuz I didn't until the last
second okay so that was there that's a
fine fine and dandy anomaly non anomaly
nomal non
omaly just make it easy for me man just
do something spooky
go
no all right
sure I sure hasn't been any
anomalies let just make sure the sign
said Concourse or exit
8 thought I heard
something okay seems
good seven yes seven all right last one
last one last one maybe one more maybe
two more I don't
know NM y n
h no Mark you're not
happy got it
perfect
something feels
wrong but I it might just be my
paranoia I swear something feels like
it's missing but
I can't tell
what it all looks fine but something in
my head is just saying that something's
off and I I can't tell what it
is but I I have no
idea what it would
be I think it's
fine oh my God why was I thinking I'm
that I knew it was just paranoia I knew
it was don't overlook any anomalies if
you find an anomaly turn around
immediately if you don't find anomalies
Don't Turn back no Mark you're not happy
don't overlook any anomalies I what it
always said now I'm being
paranoid
you haven't changed in a bit have you
have you
pal making it too
easy making it too
difficult thanks
light I hate
this why am I thinking that it didn't
always say don't overlook any anomalies
I thought it said like look carefully
for an
anomalies
oh
anomaly well that one was easy okay good
good oh my goodness now I don't have to
debate it hi pal Exit 8 Exit 8 okay
don't ever look in the anomalies okay
turn around immediately to go out from
exit 8 to go out from exit
okay
no
no no the text was on the bottom the
text for no smoking was on the
bottom it's not on the top
no no no no no no no no no no no maybe
that's what called out to me last time
but I'm telling you that wasn't the way
it
was oh my God no no what do you mean
wasn't am I crazy
no
no oh my God
I oh my God oh my
God oh man am I that
stupid oh
man oh
man
oh
uh-huh yeah
okay God damn it look we can all
collectively agree that I'm paranoid and
sometimes overthinking things the thing
is my brain is too big and therefore
sometimes things just get away from me
because of my huge big brain my
incredible
smartness weren't there always three
exclamations I don't remember there
being
four now I'm getting paranoid there's no
way that oh what the freck never mind
yeah there were always four and also the
eyes weren't darting back and
forth I am making myself so so paranoid
okay back up to five I'm doing
great should have known my acronym no
Mark
Bo nope I don't need to I I I don't need
to even get any closer to that I I don't
I don't need to no the answer is
no why why would I do
that nope nope nope nope no NOP nope
nope nope
nope
no
okay
great
great that was
fine that was fine watch out for
um title waves of
blood blood tsunamis I have a lot of
experience with them not fun okay here
we go eight again okay
eight no Mark you're not happy
good what you got for me make it easy
let's go ahead and make it
easy not going to make it easy are
you it was
easy now it's not easy
thanks
seems
fine seems good
even seems
solid so here we
go what what was the
problem what was the problem that's the
same that's fine that's
fine that's
fine that's all good numbers the same
numbers are the
same what was the problem what was the
problem oh my God are you kidding I
thought I saw something in the
reflection I thought I saw something but
I was like ah just it's just oh my God
God damn damn it damn
it damn it in case you didn't see it was
a face was in the ceiling very faint
face in the ceiling you know
casual ceiling face you seen any faces
in the ceiling or whatever shut
up oh what did I miss
God what did I miss what was it
what was it oh turn back turn back I
didn't look at the back of the sign God
damn it all right this is the one
everybody buckle up because we're about
to go into hyperdrive no nope NOP
nope no no fine you are you all right oh
whoa no no yes what are you I'm going in
Let Me
In whoa what did I see down there
all right we were we we were at level
zero anyway I wanted to see what was
inside the door that just opened up
magically because that's pretty
cool all right now we got to buckle up
everybody we're about to win this for me
for you for all of us seems
good I was wrong what was wrong vence
are the same cameras are the same that's
the same that's the same that's the same
oh my
god well okay it's more obvious when you
do it there I guess when I was running
away I didn't noticed
that y thanks good I think I'm going to
unlock all of them I'm going to find
every single one of
these that's been my goal from the
beginning camera light
everything up top exit8 no smoking
that's good that's good that's good
that's good that's good that's not good
not good not
good not good you seem fine this is good
that's good you're not moving that says
Concourse that lights on every door
handle's in the right place we're good
to go
[__] what happened what
happened is it ceiling face oh my God it
is seiling face again all right here we
go camera uh line on the ground uh first
glance nope something wrong over there I
don't even need to
check good all right this is it this is
it here we go camera nope all right
we're good we're good we're good we're
good we're good are we good please tell
me wait that doesn't seem fair that I
would have to do it
again because I got
it you know what I
mean I did unless this is
normal is it
normal it would just be normal because
now I go home
right no face in the
ceiling okay it's
Norm I just go
home I
just I just go
home I go
home
there we
go so just because you got the stairs
before it doesn't mean you got the
ending credits I did it and I'm great
and I feel great and everything about
what I do is great so
I have
escaped that's all that matters I'm very
happy about that and that was a good
game it was very clever I was actually
surprised at how many new things I kept
discovering anyway all right that's all
thank you so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye